the president arriving to cast his vote
igor don says he represents continuity
and that for him also means keeping
moldova firmly
under moscow's influence voted today for
peace and stability
for harmony between different ethnic
groups in moldova and for balancing
relations with our overseas partners
it is not an opinion shared by his
opponent
maya santo leads a party that is
representing an alternative
agenda unlike president dadon she
envisages a moldova that is no longer
so closely tied with what russia and its
president vladimir putin
wants i voted for the country that
fights corruption and wishes to stop
all these corrupt clans i voted for the
future of our country
for all of the civilized
in this ex-soviet country wedged between
ukraine
and european union member romania there
is often a clash of ideals
president dodon has cultivated warm
relations with moscow
but there is plenty affinity here for
the west yet
moldova has also had to contend with
being one of europe's
poorest nations for years its younger
generations have gone abroad in search
of work
leaving behind fewer people of working
age and an economy reliant on
remittances
conditions that have left a population
weary of more promises of change
in these elections despite the pandemic
moldovans living abroad have felt
compelled to vote
double the number than those who voted
in the last presidential elections in
2016.
but voted transparency has also been an
issue in particular in the breakaway
region of transinistria
which has been a valuable buffer for
russian interests in moldova
a hub for voter corruption in favor of
pro-moscow candidates so this
is the border crossing to trans and
austria the breakaway region that's only
recognized by russia
now there have been allegations of vote
rigging coming from this region so what
the local moldovans have done
is blocked the road to try and stop them
from coming in and voting here
the main candidates represent opposite
ends of the political spectrum in
moldova
and it is the voters who will choose
whether the country opts for
an eastern or western back leader
to help take it forward in this
turbulent time
now while president dardon may be
perhaps looking at exactly why
he's lagging behind of course it is due
to the fact that perhaps people want to
change
from his govern from his presidency but
also what it could be down to the fact
is that
during this whole campaign president
very much
played to his own audience and not
trying and not making any attempts to
reach out beyond that as well
nevertheless in two weeks time there
will be the second round of this that
will determine
who will be the next president and there
will be many attempts to form
uh deals with other smaller parties to
see if they can
form support blocks that will choose and
and decide really who will emerge as the
victor
and we'll be watching that run off for
you here on al jazeera senator diego
there on the ground for us in moldova
thank you sonia